>> CNN'S BRIAN SELTZER GETTING A
TASTE OF HIS OWN MEDICINE,
CONFRONTED BY A COLLEGE FRESHMAN
ON THE INFORMATION'S NETWORK
SPEWS OUT ON A DAILY BASIS.
>> THEY PUSHED TO THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION HOAX, THEY PUSHED THE
JESSE'S MILLETT HOST, THEY
SMEARED JUSTICE KAVANAUGH AS A
RACIST AND YES, THEY DISMISSED
THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP OF
PHARAOH'S PURE RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
ALL OF THE MISTAKES OF THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND CNN IN
PARTICULAR SEEMED TO MAGICALLY
ALL GO IN ONE DIRECTION.
ARE WE EXPECTED TO BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS ALL JUST SOME SORT OF
RANDOM COINCIDENCE?
>> IT'S TIME FOR LUNCH.
>> I THINK YOU ARE DESCRIBING A
DIFFERENT CHANNEL THAN THE ONE
NIGHT THAT I WATCH.
I UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S A POPULAR
RIGHT-WING NARRATIVE ABOUT CNN
BID LAST TIME I SPOKE WITH A
BITE MADE WE YELLED AT EACH
OTHER.
>> SO, GREG, WHAT'S YOUR
ANALYSIS.
ARE YOU SURPRISED THAT BRIAN'S
SELTZER'S FIRST REACTION IS IT'S
TIME TO GET OUT TO LUNCH?
>> AND IT WASN'T ONLY 9:00 A.M.
HE DOESN'T WATCH HIS OWN
NETWORK, THAT'S THE FIRST POINT.
NUMBER TWO IT'S PRETTY FUNNY TO
SEE CNN HOSTING A SYMPOSIUM ON
DISINFORMATION, UNLESS IT IS A
HOW-TO.
IT'S A PARODY OF ITSELF.
CNN'S ENTIRE PROFIT MODEL IS NOT
REPORTING GOOD NEWS, IT'S
CREATING THOSE.
THE PRODUCERS SHAPE THE
NARRATIVE THAT ARE DESIGNED TO
CREATE CONTEXT AND FILL UP ALL
OF THOSE HOURS OF EMPTY SPACE
AND EMPTY HEADS, THAT'S THE
PROBLEM PEER THE PROBLEM WITH
CNN IS THAT THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
BORING -- TO JUSTIFY ITS
EXISTENCE.
THAT'S WHY THEIR ANCHORS BECAME
COMMENTATORS WITHOUT BEING
LABELED AS SUCH.
AT FOX WE DELINEATE WHO IS A
NEWS PERSON AND WHOSE
COMMENTATOR.
I CHEW THE FAT, WILD BRET BAIER
AND BILL HEMMER REPORT THE NEWS.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
WE HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
VIEWERS SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
TRICK THEM WITH THESE ARTIFICIAL
NARRATIVES ON THIS LOW NEWS.
THE FACT THAT HE PLAYED DOWN,
AND MAYBE HE WASN'T -- HE WAS
KIND OF EMBARRASSING.
THE GUY BROUGHT -- HE BROUGHT
THE EVIDENCE -- HE LISTED EVERY
STORY.
IT WASN'T LIKE THE KID WALKED UP
AND SAID WHY ARE YOU GUYS DO AND
ALL THAT FAKE NEWS?
HE WENT THROUGH AND HE MADE THE
MOST IMPORTANT POINT, THAT EVERY
BIAS GOES IN ONE DIRECTION.
WE'VE MADE A POINT MANY TIMES.
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
YOUNG MAN COHOSTING FOX AND FREE
FRIENDS WEEKEND IN 2028.
>> OF THE STUDENT DID LIST A
NUMBER OF STORIES, BRIAN SELTZER
FANCIES HIMSELF A MEDIA
JOURNALIST WHO COVERS THE NEWS.
AND THEY ARE DESPERATE FOR
CREDIBILITY.
DID HE MISS AN OPPORTUNITY HERE
TO TRY AND MAKE AMENDS AND SAY
WE COULD HAVE COVERED THESE
THINGS A BIT DIFFERENTLY.
THESE ARE THE THINGS WE NEED TO
DO BETTER ON NEXT TIME.
>> IN ALL OF THE STORIES HE
LISTED FELL APART.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE STORIES,
WHICH THEY SPENT AN ENORMOUS --
IF THEY SPENT ENOUGH TIME
INVESTIGATING THEM AS THEY DID
TRYING TO SHOVE THEM DOWN
EVERYBODY'S THROAT THEY WOULD'VE
BEEN DOING SOME GOOD JOURNALISM.
THE END THEY WOULD HAVE FIGURED
IT OUT.
A NUMBER OF THOSE STORIES WE
WERE SKEPTICAL ON FROM THE
BEGINNING.
AND WE MADE A GOOD EFFORT TO
LOOK AT BOTH SIDES OF THE STORY.
I THINK IT IS HILARIOUS STUDIES
LIKE IT'S TIME TO GO TO LUNCH,
THEN HE SAYS AFTER THAT TO THE
KID HE SAYS I'LL COME TALK TO
YOU AFTER THIS.
YOU AND ME WORKING HAVE A LITTLE
CHAT.
BUT I DO WANT TO GIVE YOU YOUR
DUE -- I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS, BUT HE'S
NOT GOING TO DO IT UP THERE ON
THE PODIUM.
I JUST THINK THE TITLE OF
THIS -- I'M SO TIRED -- THE
DISINFORMATION AND THE EROSION
OF DEMOCRACY.
SUBTITLE, RIGHT?
YOU KNOW THEY ARE JUST BRING
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DOESN'T RUN
AGAIN COME OR THEY ARE PRAYING
THAT HE DOES.
EITHER WAY.
THEIR RATINGS HAVE TANKED SINCE
THEY HAD PRESIDENT TRUMP TO POKE
OUT EVERY DAY.
BUT THIS IS JUST BECOME SUCH A
CATCH PHRASE THAT MEANS EXACTLY
WHAT EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT IT
MEANS.
SO, JESSE, DOES THE WHOLE
MISINFORMATION DISINFORMATION --
IS NOT JUST CODE FOR WE DON'T
LIKE WITH BEING SET ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND THEREFORE WE
WOULD LIKE CENSORSHIP FOR ANY
OUTLET OR MEDIA THAT DOESN'T
AGREE WITH OUR MISTAKES OR OUR
NARRATIVE?
>> YOU NAILED IT, KATIE.
HE MADE SOME GREAT POINTS WILL
BE SHORT -- HOW OLD IS HE?
45?
A GROWN MAN?
>> THE STUDENT?
>> NO, SELTZER.
>> NO HE'S LIKE 12.
AN 18-YEAR-OLD KID SHOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO LEAVE YOU SPEECHLESS.
AND SEARCHING FOR A COHERENT
ANSWER.
YOU ARE A GROWN MAN, YOUR
PROFESSIONAL.
YOU'RE ON CNN.
IF YOU CAN HANDLE A TEENAGER YOU
DO NOT DESERVE TO BE ON THERE.
I WILL SAY HE'S A MUCH BETTER
WRITER --
>> HE'S 36.
>> IS 36?
I WILL THOUGHT IT WAS --
NEVER MIND.
I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THAT --
SORRY.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO HANDLE A
COLLEGE FRESHMAN.
I'M HEARING FROM MY SOURCES,
KATIE, THAT HE'S NOT LONG FOR
THEM FOR CNN.
THEY DON'T LIKE HIM THERE.
THEY MIGHT ACTUALLY CUT THEM
LOOSE.
HE DID SAY SOMETHING THAT WAS
INTERESTING.
HE SAID WE HAVE TO APOLOGIZE
WHEN WE GET THINGS WRONG.
HE DIDN'T APOLOGIZE FOR ANY OF
THAT STUFF.
EXCEPT YOU COULD CALLED THE
SANDMAN'S THE SETTLEMENT AND
APOLOGY.
>> JESSICA.
THERE IS A SUGAR -- NOW THE
EDITOR OF THE ATLANTIC IS
BASICALLY STEERING THEM AND
SAYING THAT THEIR CONFERENCE HAS
BEEN ATTACKED BY DISINFORMATION
AS A RESULT OF THE STUDENT
SHOWING UP.
SIMPLY ASKING QUESTIONS IN A
FORUM WHERE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE OPEN ON A COLLEGE CAMPUS TO
DIFFERENT IDEAS AND
PERSPECTIVES.
>> ESPECIALLY AT AN INSTITUTION
LIKE THE UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO.
WHEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
TOP OF THE TOP HERE.
I THINK THAT IT'S A GOOD THING
TO BE PUSHED ON THESE THINGS.
I THINK YOU SHOULD HAVE AN
ANSWER READY.
IF THERE'S SOMETHING I'VE
BROUGHT UP I'M READY TO DEFEND
IT OR AT LEAST TO SAY I WAS
WRONG ABOUT THIS, AND THAT'S WHY
I HAVE BEEN CAUTIOUS ABOUT
CERTAIN SCANDALS.
NOW WE DON'T HAVE TIME FOR THIS,
I DON'T WANT TO TALK -- FOR ME
AND FOR MANY PEOPLE WITH
POLITICAL BELIEFS LISTENING WHAT
CAME OUT IN THE MUELLER PROBE
WAS NOT A HOAX.
MUELLER MADE IT CLEAR IN HIS
2019 TESTIMONY THAT HE DID NOT
EXONERATE DONALD TRUMP.
>> YOU JUST HAVE TO COME ARE
PRESUMED NOT GUILTY.
>> THAT'S NOT THE POINT HERE.
WHAT HAPPENED IN THAT MEETING
WAS AN APPLE BOMB EARLY IN THE
WEEK AND SAID SOMETHING ABOUT
WHERE THE COUNTRY IS GOING
BECAUSE OF HOW YOUNG PEOPLE ARE.
GEN Z AND YOUNGER MILLENNIALS
ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
TRADITIONAL PARTY POLITICS.
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN BEING
PERSUADED.
THEY WANT PEOPLE WITH A KIND OF
IDEAS THAT ALIGN WITH THEIR
VALUES, SO THEY CARE ABOUT
THINGS LIKE THE ENVIRONMENT,
EVEN THE YOUNG REPUBLICANS CARE
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND BELIEVE
THAT IT'S MAN-MADE THEN OLDER
REPUBLICANS.
IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
POLITICIANS AND MEDIA OUTLETS TO
MAKE SURE THEY ARE TAKING THESE
AND PEOPLE SERIOUSLY IN ORDER TO
MAKE THEM EITHER LOYAL VIEWERS
ARE PEOPLE THAT WILL COME OUT
AND VOTE FOR YOU.
THAT'S A LOT OF MISSED
OPPORTUNITY THAT GOES ON IN
THESE CONFERENCES WHEN PEOPLE
JUST KIND OF SEND THEM TO THE
SIDE AND SAY THIS IS B.S. OR
WHATEVER ON THIS ONE IS SAYING
IT'S NOT MY POLITICAL ALIGNMENT.
THIS IS THE NEW FACE OF OUR
GENERATIONS.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY DID SOME
ANYONE ANY FAVOR